Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that if
you have a message for me, you can call that
number is 2192. David P Here is an interesting
voicemail from a Republican who says they are a
Republican. I didn't convert them out of being
Republicans, but they have changed their mind
about at least some issues and they like the
show. Interesting message from a Republican.
Speaker 3: Hey, how you doing, David? John from
Massachusetts. Thank you. I'd say I'm actually a
registered Republican, but I do enjoy your show.
You definitely. I actually started listening to
it driving home from work. And it's beautiful.
You know, I was like, wow, this guy's, you know,
talking out of his ass. I mean, part of my line.
Speaker 1: That's the reaction from even
people that like the show. So,
no, no concerns there, sir.
Speaker 3: You know, I honestly, you definitely
grew on me and you definitely changed my mind
about something. There you go.
Speaker 1: And I'd be curious
what things those are, by the way.
Speaker 3: I really do enjoy when you're making
fun of Donald Trump. Oh, that's very funny. Just
got to say, if you keep that up, you do a pretty
good. You just. I probably I should come on your
show as a guest. So an impersonator, you know what
I'm saying? It would just be so great. So thank
you so much, David, and have a wonderful day.
Speaker 1: All right. The Trump impression is
so-so. I don't know that that's the best moment of
the voice mail. But listen, we have a ton of right
wingers in the audience who I never hear from,
who don't insult me, who don't say anti-Semitic
things, who don't make threats, who just listen
to get a different opinion. And sometimes we
find points of agreement. And that's a really
great thing. I welcome that. I think that that's
fantastic. If I'm only speaking to left wingers,
what the hell am I doing at the end of the
day? So beautiful voicemail. Great to hear
from you. We have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. Oklahoma voters have rejected legalizing
recreational cannabis. What is this, the first
such failure? We will discuss. The White House
has endorsed a new Senate tick tock bill and is
urging Congress to pass it quickly. Does that make
sense? Should tick tock be banned or should it be
regulated or should it be controlled or whatever
the case may be? We will discuss. And lastly, New
York City Mayor Eric Adams is now telling stores
to have customers remove their masks when they
come in in order to try to cut down on shoplifting
and thefts and burglary and robbery or whatever
the term is that is appropriate. Stick ups,
I guess, is what we're calling them. I don't
know. You all understand what I'm saying?
Remove the mask. Eric Adams says so that they
would be identified on your security cameras
and maybe be less likely to do it. Interesting.
All of those stories and more when I'm joined by
producer Pat on the bonus show. You can sign up
at join Packman dot com. You can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a discount
and save big off of the cost of a membership. I
welcome you all to the bonus show if you are
not a member. We will be back with the new
show tomorrow. But why wait? We can be together
again in just a few minutes on the bonus track.